It's like death staring at
you when you look at a camera.
It's kind of scary also.
I'm speaking to filmmakers,
our future filmmakers.
You have to know I have
gone through all of this.
I have learned it all on my own.
[INAUDIBLE]
Shit yeah.
This is good stuff.
And know there's
something I can pass on.
For example, I do
not use a storyboard.
I think it's an
instrument of the cowards.
Acting, embarking with actors--
for me, it's chemistry,
understanding the world
and understanding human beings.
Hold a camera.
Don't look at the flip screen.
Look through it.
There's one book I
would ask you to read
if you want to make films.
You'll spend way too much
time in the film school.
It costs way too much money.
You can learn the essentials
of filmmaking on your own
within two weeks.
And I see young filmmakers
who come excitedly at me,
and they say, oh,
I shot 450 hours.
My heart sinks.
We are not garbage collectors.
We are filmmakers.
We are thieves.
We get away with loot
from the most beautiful
or the most scary or the
most spectacular places
that you can ever find.
Just hit and run and
get away with film.
I'm Werner Herzog, and
this is my Masterclass.